you know we have to kick it off with a
crop of fresh golden globe nominations
and yes
you may notice we're in mourning this is
us under here
and that's because bridgette was totally
snapped
our beloved bridgerton why would they do
that i don't know
i don't know i mean with the highest
breaking records you know on netflix the
business alone it is the biggest show uh
in like the longest time i think it's
it's still the number one show streamed
on on netflix it looked like it was
going to get all these nominations
nothing not a one not a one so we'll
just have to wait till the emmys when
those nominations are out and our will
keep the our little veil you know what
it's fantastic about the golden globe
three female directors this year first
time ever extraordinary absolutely
wonderful uh regina king chloe zao and
emerald fennel all got nods i mean
that's like just a beautiful thing well
you think about what that looks like
just we've never had more women than men
it was used to be a big deal when we'd
have one pendulum swung us the other way
uh chadwick boseman got a nomination
so good in mommy's black bottom yeah i
think i thought that was an incredibly
soulful respectful beautiful thing i i'm
happy for the crown obviously we had
emma and josh here on the show who
played uh charles and diana they were
extraordinary
i missed penn 15 and
and i may destroy you i would have loved
to have seen those shows get recognized
and maybe we can wait for the emmys for
that well you know i love award seasons
and the golden globe is really the
kickoff for like the movie awards
seasons because it sort of says these
are what you know the oscar people what
could be nominee for an oscar coming up
and uh the movies like trial chicago
seven yeah got a lot of numbers
the nominations there's a black and
white film but yeah adventure i love
promising young woman and glenn close
nominated for hillbilly elegy for
playing uh most of my relatives
that's just like if you haven't seen
that movie uh she's so good in that too
so the other thing is so interesting now
about the golden globes is a lot of time
when these movies are nominated people
are like what is that i've never heard
but because of the pandemic a lot of
these movies are streamable right now
absolutely the ones i mentioned a lot of
them on netflix or amazon prime so
google and find out and you can watch
them right at home well we have someone
who can come and join us and give her
um give us her opinion uh of which i
highly respect um she is a very very
funny lady comedian an actress a new
york times best-selling author over and
over again
another great form in our medium now is
podcasts and she has an awesome one it's
called go ask ally it is out now i
believe it's season two please welcome
allie wentworth ally
oh look how good you look
i was gonna wear a veil too because i'm
very upset but i only could find my
wedding veil which sends a different
message
or does it maybe when your fabulous
husband george stephanopoulos comes home
you know you could um hello have that
kind of an evening
nothing sexier than me with the big bail
on my head
well i'm so interested to hear like your
opinion did you enjoy the nominations
did you feel like someone was missing
out what are you celebrating what are
your what is ali wentworth's thoughts
i thought it was an interesting golden
globes year i was very upset about
um but a promising young woman is a
fantastic movie so i was thrilled and i
hope carrie mulligan uh wins because i
don't know if you guys saw that piece
about somebody in variety said oh you
know it would have been better if they
had someone hotter like uh margot robbie
which i thought was so enraging to say
that carrie mulligan wasn't hot enough
was extremely offensive so i'm i'm i'm
hoping she's going to win and she called
out that reviewer too and the variety
redacted it they apologized i'm shocked
that sends a poor taste um
i also know she's married um to mumford
and sons i think they're like the
coolest couple and they have kids and
they're just amazing and she's amazing
i'm obsessed and she burst onto seeing
um the scene in an education yeah she
has been an absolute award-nominated
recognized highly acclaimed actress and
this is her moment which is so exciting
[Music]